[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right now this is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
yeah Wow the arrogance of them so far
hundreds and hundreds of challengers not
one winner yep
we don't make mistakes I think they're
the ones making the mistake in
questioning us thank you thank you thank
you well tonight a fan named Rob Gunn
Salvas thinks he caught a mistake he
says it happened on October 1st during
my interview with Adam Scott :
you really made mistake this time you
were talking to Adam Scott about how he
threw out a pitch the Dodgers game it's
deceptive because on TV obviously when
people they just watch the baseball
primarily on television it's deceptive
that's that's 90 feet 90 feet you think
it's 90 feet to throw a ball from the
pitcher's mound home plate that's wrong
it's 60 foot 6 inches don't know it's 90
feet to go from home base to first base
but you have to multiply by the square
root of 2 over 2 which is its feet 6
inches you made on the steak
like I does his steel paintings from
motels
[Applause]
well I'm sorry Rob but you're dead wrong
I did say 90 feet but I was not
referring to the distance from the
pitcher's mound to home plate and if he
would bother to watch the rest of the
interview that night you'd know that
take a look it's deceptive that's that's
90 feet oh whoa we we lost power Adam
this has never happened before during an
interview I'm really sorry
[Applause]
it's quite a response for a blackout I
know that's the most excited of crowds
ever been that the lights just came back
on when you've been out here a few
minutes I know anyway we're talking
about baseball right back to baseball
yeah so wait a second did you just say
that it's 90 feet between the pitcher's
mound and home plate because that would
be batshit crazy no of course not
I was talking about my own experience at
Dodger Stadium when I threw out the
ceremonial first relay from second base
to first base to complete a double play
of course a double double play relay
Todd yes yeah it's Dodger Stadium
highest celebrity honor and it's exactly
90 feet right that's right even showed a
replay of it I think during the Dodgers
Cardinals playoff game
careful there Adam remember I'm
interviewing you interviewing you on
October 1st so we have no idea which
team will make the play all right
[Applause]
yeah October 1st so the Obamacare
website goes online today and I can tell
you it'll be glitch free Oh anyway
that's exactly Andy how I remember the
Adam Scott interview going I don't
remember it that way at all it's exactly
how it happened yep it's happened
[Music]
so the challenge still stands if think
you spotted an arrow on our show
reported a team koco.com / - that ever
will sort it out here on the air let's
see if you've got what it takes to make
junk meat out of the maestro